[Música]
imaginen una mirada
no una mirada de amor
de una mirada de odio o terror
sino una mirada indiferente
qué te hace sentir como si vos fueras
diferente al resto
como si te rechazan tanto alrededor y a
su vez te miran con cara de asombro
una vez pasión en el shopping sentido
justo esa mirada
a mirar a mi alrededor y ver cómo la
gente se codeaba y murmuraba me di
cuenta que no me miraban a mí sino que
miraban a mis amigas
no podía entender por qué la miraban así
si docente que sería igual a mí
hasta que me puse mirarle a ella y me di
cuenta que la miraban así porque tenía
una diferente forma de caminar
y porque usaba un andador ahora
seguramente se están preguntando qué
tiene mi amiga
mi amiga tiene una diversidad funcional
pero esperen la mayoría de los que están
acá lo saben lo que es una diversidad
funcional es lo mismo que yo me pregunte
cuando escuché la expresión
diversidad funcional es una idea
utilizada para evitar señalar a las
personas con discapacidad utilizando una
frase que hace referencia a que pueden
hacer pero distinto ni mejor ni peor a
lo que se venía considerando como normal
volviendo a lo anterior mi amiga tiene
una diversidad funcional causada por su
nacimiento con hemiparesia o sea que los
músculos de su lado izquierdo no les
funcionan tan bien
pero cuando estoy con ella siento que yo
soy esa parte izquierda que no les
funciona me acuerdo una vez que una
amiga que tenemos en común nos invitó a
su fiesta de quince
como no teníamos decidido que ponernos
decidimos juntarnos antes para ver que
nos íbamos a poner y como no teníamos
nada decidido
su hermana vino y nos prestó ropa nos
probamos un montón de outfits y como no
nos convenció nada
decidimos ponernos algo común un short
un top y unos zapatos
nos maquillamos y vino su papá para
llevarnos a la fiesta
comimos bailaron el vals y nos prendimos
a bailar como todos
y una mujer nos miraba
no se acercó a hablarnos y no la trataba
normal la trataba diferente
como infantilizando todo el momento no
la trataba mal tampoco pero la trata
como si fuese una nena
a mí ya esas capas en su momento ahora
nos da gracias porque ya tenemos rey
naturalizado que la gente actuó de esa
forma estando cerca de ella pero yo creo
que esas cosas son las que a ellos le
hacen sentir como si fuera diferente una
vez
eso me contó
que en su nuevo colegio
la tienen que acompañar siempre para ir
en la cantina porque como tiene el
andador no se puede meter en el medio de
toda la gente para comprar
y le pidió una compañera que la
compañera y la compañera desde la otra
punta le grita no te quiero acompañar
esa cuando me lo dijo me dijo se me
parte el corazón
y yo creo que cuando me lo contó también
se me parte el corazón a mí
por eso yo les propongo que si ustedes
se cruzan con una persona que tenga
diversidad funcional que no les excluyan
porque a esa persona le importa mucho lo
que vos pienses de ella como nos pasa a
todos los adolescentes
porque son calificadas por lo que se ve
por fuera y no se dan la oportunidad de
conocerlas por dentro
y muy rara vez son incluidas
que no se dejen llevar por la mirada de
los ojos sino que por la mirada del
corazón
y así logren tener lo mismo que yo tengo
con mi amiga que es esta amistad tan
grande gracias
[Aplausos]
ah
a
[Música]